wall toall lies that's the focus of
tonight's
angle oh they were so full of themselves
Joe Biden declared Trump's border wall
dead on day one and just two months ago
Biden's people were gleefully selling
off portions of the border wall as an
Administration run by far-left
globalists they've always believed that
any border or policy that prevents
people from entering our country is
inhumane there will not be another foot
of Wall constructed on my
Administration thus last night's
Announcement by the Biden DHS secretary
that they were going to start building a
wall on the southern border seemed like
kind of policy Whiplash mayorca cited an
acute and immediate need to wave federal
laws and begin building a border wall in
south Texas now when the news broke many
were shocked but not the angle we told
you to expect this last
month
the angle believes that the White House
maybe maybe considering a move to at
least have the appearance of tightening
things at the border now just so you
understand this this is not because
somehow Joe Biden who doesn't think
about anything but any the people
puppets puppeteers controlling Biden
have some policy Epiphany on the issue
but because it's become a huge political
liability to them and three we Weeks
Later the Biden people know they do have
a full-blown political crisis on their
hands and we're not just talking about
the
polling That's The Simple Solution is no
turn the buses around we come in a
community of black people where we
already get the low scraps and then you
want to take the little scrap the
resources that we have and put us at the
bottom of the barrel that's not fair we
want them to have a limit on who can
come across the border it is too open
right now and we're doing everything we
can but we need more help from the
federal government and we need need more
help overall to solve for this of course
the White House is trying to have it
both ways here trying to reclaim some
credit on the border while staving off a
full-fledged Rebellion from its far Left
Flank now pretending that the new Biden
border wall was just some budgetary
requirement the border wall the money
was appropriated for the border wall I
tried to get them to reappropriate to
redirect that money they didn't they
wouldn't and in the meantime there's
nothing under the law other than they
have to use the money for what was
appropriated I can't stop that do you
believe the border wall burs no okay if
this is their attempt at playing
three-dimensional chess they shouldn't
have involved a guy better suited to
tossing around one of those big plastic
beach balls at the senior center okay
the White House's explanation was so
tortured that even the sympathetic press
Corp was pushing them on it today's
edition of Story Time with kgp JP was
one for the agent is what specific law
will the administration be breaking if
funds appropriated for the border wall
are not used especially because the
funds are go unused all the time and why
not let it go unused this time well look
I'm not going to speak to uh the law I
would have to refer you to Department of
Justice I'm not a lawyer but what I can
tell you is that we are comp we are uh
this is a law that we are complying with
and we believe that uh in the rule of
law here and we're moving forward and
getting that and in in following the law
the did she just say the rule of law
these people are such frauds and now
Homeland Security is trying to do a
major cleanup on aisle 3 claiming that
the first statement they put out didn't
really say what it really says there is
no new Administration policy with
respect to the border wall from day one
this Administration has made clear that
a border wall is not the answer that
remains our position and our position
has never wavered now these people
aren't just Fanatics they're complete
incompetence and they're bad liars and
Trump well he predicted all of it Biden
wins your borders are gone which means
your health care is gone the middle
class is gone your safety is gone your
country is gone that's what's going to
happen and since election night 2020
millions of illegals knew that no
borders Biden would give them a free
pass and the cartels well they got their
own free pass as well now they're
rolling in cash while the bodies of
Overdose victims are rolling into the
morgs Across America so spare us any new
fake sense of urgency On the Border this
has been an ongoing emergency a crisis
of Biden's own making that they
adamantly refused to admit was a crisis
for
years but look here's the bottom line
they want open borders period they'll
only even pretend to secure the borders
if they feel in enormous political
pressure and even then they're going to
do as little as possible to enforce our
laws that's the truth everything else
everything else is a lie and the lies
are going to continue and the crisis
will grow until the American people
change the party in the White House and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else